Thomas Jäger Politikwissenschaftler der
Universität Köln ist mir zugeschaltet
guten Tag Herr Jäger einen schönen guten
Tag Frau Dauster ja die Rede Putins
werden wir auch gleich noch einordnen zu
Beginn aber die Frage die irgendwie über
allem steht und nämlich die Frage hat
Putin auf den falschen Mann nämlich
pregorian gesetzt
das ist schwer zu sagen wir haben das in
der Vergangenheit ja so interpretiert
das brigochien durch seine Ausfälle
gegenüber schon gut und gerassimo auf
dem politischen und militärischen
Führern in der in Russland den
Handlungsspielraum von Putin erweitert
insofern als er immer gesagt hat die
sind schuld dass es hier nicht zu
erfolgen kommt die schaffen es nicht
genügend Munition und genügend Truppen
heran zu bekommen die schaffen es nicht
ein ausreichendes Führungsverhalten an
den Tag zu legen und das hat Putin die
Möglichkeit gegeben sich sozusagen an
die Seite zu stellen und es hätte einen
Sündenbock gegeben den gibt es ab jetzt
nicht mehr jetzt ist wirklich Putin für
diese Misserfolge zuständig denn er hat
sich klar hinter schon gut und gar nicht
aufgestellt und hat das Waschen macht
eben als Hochverrat bezeichnet hatte
auch eigentlich gar keine andere
Möglichkeit nach dem Goschen über Wochen
vorbereitet durch seine Reden eine einen
Angriff letztlich im Informationsraum
auf Putin der die ganze Geschichte von
der Bedrohung durch die Ukraine von dem
Verteidigungskrieg Russlands einfach zu
dem macht was es in Wahrheit ist nämlich
nichts man stellt sich jetzt die Frage
ist prigoschin stark genug wir wissen
seine seine soldat-truppe ist ungefähr
25.000 Mann stark im Vergleich dazu die
russische Armee 1,3 Millionen Soldaten
davon 840.000 aktiv der Rest in Reserve
also wer nimmt es hier
größenverhältnismäßig mit wem auf
die Frage die wir noch nicht beantworten
können weil darüber hat brigoche noch
nicht gesprochen ist wie gut ist das
vorbereitet man kann sich ja nicht
vorstellen dass das sozusagen aus einer
Laune aus einem Zorn heraus geschehen
ist und wenn er das gut vorbereitet hat
so wie die zumindest seine Maßnahme im
Informationsraum das
möglich sein lassen dann hat er
möglicherweise ein weiteres Netzwerk
über 30.000 ehemalige Wagner Kämpfer
Strafgefangene die jetzt in Russland
frei leben möglicherweise hat er auch
Kontakt zu anderen aufgenommen die über
Privatarmeen verfügen wie kadur auf etwa
aus Tschetschenien der jetzt zwar sagt
er steht an der Reihe an der Seite
Putins gegen diesen Durchstoß aber da
wird sie im Hintergrund sicher jetzt
ganz viel verhandelt wer kriegt was für
was denn das konnte man Putins reden ja
nur wirklich entnehmen da herrscht Angst
es geht jetzt um die Macht im Kreml und
Putin weiß dass er die Lage nicht mehr
kontrolliert und die große Frage ist hat
er die Sicherheitskräfte im Griff oder
hat brigosch in möglicherweise
irgendwelche Angebote die dann die
Soldaten zu ihm überlaufen lassen denn
das ist die militärische Führung nicht
tun wird das ist richtig aber er könnte
ja darauf spekulieren die
Kriegsmüdigkeit der russischen Soldaten
zu nutzen indem er etwa verspricht den
Krieg zu beenden weil er auf diese Art
und Weise nicht gewonnen werden kann ja
sie haben es erwähnt also es könnte
eventuell oder entscheidend wird jetzt
wohl sein wer sich alles auf die Seite
von prigosh ihn schlägt sie haben den
Tschetschenen kadiros genannt Gazprom
das Unternehmen Gazprom hat auch ein
oder zwei Privatarmeen gegründet und wir
wissen alle dass es um die Moral der
russischen Soldaten auch nicht besonders
gut gestellt war
ist das jetzt so einer etwas wie ein
kriegsentscheidender Moment obwohl wir
noch nicht wissen wie er ausgeht aber
wie könnte es sein nur es kommt darauf
an für welchen krieg jetzt gibt es ja
auf einmal zwei auf der einen Seite für
Russland einen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine um dort Gebiete zu besetzen und
auf der anderen Seite gibt es jetzt in
Russland militärische
Auseinandersetzungen die man sehr wohl
als Krieg unterschiedlicher Streitkräfte
bezeichnen kann denn es gibt inzwischen
Gefechte zwischen den Wagner Söldnern
und den russischen Truppen also
sozusagen Truppen die brikosin gehorchen
und Truppen die schon gut gehorchen und
das wird man sehen müssen wie das in den
nächsten Tagen jetzt ausgeht sicher wird
das eine Lage sein die sich relativ
schnell entscheidet die Rückwirkungen
auf den Krieg in der Ukraine die lassen
sich noch nicht wirklich absehen außer
dass man jetzt schon sagen kann das ist
eine für die Ukraine vorteilhafte
Situation denn Kampf erfahrene Soldaten
sind dort abgezogen worden und für die
Herrschaft im Kreml steht ab jetzt an
allererster Stelle und hat Priorität die
Macht im Kreml zu sichern also es könnte
ein günstiger Moment sein für die
Ukraine weil sich jetzt natürlich der
Fokus der der russischen Streitkräfte
erstmal auf einen anderen Feind
sozusagen richtig wie die Ukraine diesen
Moment nutzen wird werden wir sehen
lassen wir uns noch mal über die Lage in
Moskau sprechen der russischen
Hauptstadt dort sind jetzt Terror Anti
terrormaßnahmen in Kraft gesetzt was
bedeutet das tatsächlich in der
Umsetzung im Alltag was erleben die
Menschen jetzt dort in Moskau
ja zum ersten ist im Stadtbild überall
sind Sicherheitskräfte zu sehen und zwar
unterschiedliche Art von der
Geheimdiensten Polizei
Militär und das Moskau gesichert wird
auf jede erdenkliche Art und Weise das
war ja zuvor schon zu beobachten man
wird jetzt sehen müssen ob brigoch in
eine Strategie hat wie er weiter vorgeht
dass die seine Truppen jetzt auf dem Weg
sind nach Moskau und etwa die halbe
Strecke hinter sich gebracht haben bevor
sie erst erste Mal auf Widerstand
gestoßen sind hat eine Lage hergestellt
in der sie ist nun wirklich auf die
Frage ankommt wie gut ist das alles
vorbereitet dass die russische Seite auf
solche aber eine solche Maßnahme nicht
vorbereitet war das sieht man ja allein
schon dadurch dass es ihm gelang eben
eine große Stadt direkt einzunehmen und
das Kommando Süd sozusagen unter seine
Gewalt zu bringen
also jetzt wird man aber relativ schnell
in Russland reagieren und sehen dass man
die Sicherheitsorgane aufgestellt
bekommt ja also Sie haben es erwähnt
also mittlerweile hören wir dass selbst
eine bewaffnete Einheit in Baronesse
eingetroffen sei das ist ungefähr 500
Kilometer von Russland entfernt also
vielleicht noch sechseinhalb Stunden bis
man die Hauptstadt Moskau erreicht also
es wird auf jeden Fall ein spannender
Nachmittag früher Abend noch werden um
zu sehen wie sich die Lage dort
entwickelt jetzt haben wir gehört äh
Putin hat in oder der russische
Geheimdienst es FB ermittelt gegen
pregorien ihm sollen bis zu 20 Jahre
Haft drohen aber dazu wird es ja
wahrscheinlich gar nicht kommen sollte
man ihn fassen oder wie schätzen Sie die
Lage ein
nein er hat jetzt sozusagen die Anklage
gegen Hochverrat im Rücken er hat selbst
gesagt dass man bereit sei hier zu
fallen in diesem Waffengang den er
begonnen hat das wird sicher mit Gewalt
entschieden und
möglicherweise
ist das sozusagen ein Prozess der
relativ schnell geht wenn es denn
russischen Truppen gelingt sich
entsprechend aufzustellen das könnte
sich aber eben im Land auch noch je
nachdem welche
sozusagen Resonanz es findet ganz anders
darstellen
Jäger bis hierhin wir sprechen gleich
noch einmal wir hören jetzt aber erst
noch mal einen ein Statement vom Chef
der wagnertruppe Söldner nämlich von
gregorien
wir befinden uns im Stab der sonder für
Operation ist der 7.30 unter unserer
Kontrolle sind alle militärko Objekte in
Rostow darunter auch der Flughafen da
hat die Militärflugzeuge die an der
Frontlinie im Einsatz sind setzen ihre
Arbeit fort sowie auch die
sanitätsflugzeuge das einzige was wir
gemacht haben also die Kontrolle
übernommen damit die Militärflugzeuge
nicht uns sondern die Ukraine angreifen
die
Leitungsorgane der Streitkräfte arbeitet
wie gewohnt die jeder Offizier ist am
Arbeitsplatz und wir stören die Arbeit
der Stadt nicht und als
als wir hierher gekommen sind müssen wir
feststellen er norbertätorien sind
verloren worden enorm
Menschen in Massen sind verloren worden
um mehrfach mehr als offiziell bekannt
gegeben wird die sanitätsverlust pro Tag
machen manchmal bis 1000 Menschen aus
das sind die getöteten die Verwundeten
und die Verweigerer es mangelt an
Munition und es mangelt an der Leitung
die Menschen sind in der gastgasse der
Chef des äh Stabs ist geflogen worden
sofort erfahren hat dass wir uns dem
Gebäude nähern
so das war der Chef der Söldnertruppe
wagnerin der sich in der Vergangenheit
wir haben darüber gesprochen ja immer
wieder auch mit dem russischen
Verteidigungsminister schon gelegt hatte
oder sich beschwert hatte auch mit dem
Generalstab Chef jetzt aber offenbar
richtet sich der Kampf direkt gegen den
Präsidenten gegen den russischen Staat
sozusagen oder
ja das hat sich gestern angedeutet als
in langen Stellungnahmen eben eine
völlig ganz eine völlig andere
Darstellung der Ursachen dieses Krieges
gegeben hat als das Präsident Putin Tat
und da war sichtbar dass hier an Bruch
erfolgt ist und der große Schritt war
dann eben nicht nur auf telegram
irgendwelche Reden zu veröffentlichen
das war schon Provokation genug aber in
dem Moment in dem man eben den ersten
Panzer startet und losfährt und die
Richtung moskau ist in dem Moment waren
die würfelge gefallen und standpräsident
Putin unter dem Zwang sich eben so
äußern zu müssen weil seine Herrschaft
jetzt gefährdet ist denn das ist ja so
Russland befindet sich im Krieg
Präsident Putin erzählt seiner
Bevölkerung die ganze Zeit dass der
gesamte Westen Russland zerstören wolle
was völliger uns ist um das gleich dazu
zu sagen und er ist nun der
Oberbefehlshaber der die Lage nicht in
unter Kontrolle hat Putin ist die
Situation entglitten wir sehen hier
nebenbei Bilder aus Moskau ganz aktuelle
Bilder der Situation wir sehen dass
Straßen gesperrt sind rund um den
Präsidenten Palast wir haben gehört dass
anti-terrormaßnahmen in Kraft gesetzt
wurden Moskau die Hauptstadt Russlands
wird also geschützt vor einem womöglich
bevorstehenden Einmarsch bewaffneter
Truppen oder Gruppen der der
Söldnergruppe Wagner Herr Jäger lassen
Sie uns noch mal auf die Rede von
Präsident Putin schauen die ihr heute
Vormittag 10 Uhr russischer Zeit in
russischen Staatsfernsehen gegeben hat
sie haben es angesprochen sein narrativ
der Westen greife Russland an das ist
ein altbekanntes und ein falsches
darüber haben wir haben das haben Sie
auch schon
deutlich gemacht und gleichzeitig haben
wir in dieser Rede auch ähm Worte wie
Deutsch gestoßen gehört also eine eine
Rhetorik die an den ersten weltkrieger
erinnert und die Frage an Sie
ob wie stark oder schwach sie Präsident
Putin in dieser Rede wahrgenommen haben
ist völlig in die Ecke gedrängt er hat
die Lage nicht unter Kontrolle eine
solche Rede will niemand halten der
seine Streitkräfte gegen ein anderes
Land gewendet hat und das wird ja in der
Bevölkerung völlig deutlich wahrgenommen
dass hier eine Situation entstanden ist
in der Kämpfer die die ganze Zeit als
diejenigen dargestellt wurden die so das
russische narrativ wiederum heldenhaft
Gebiete befreit haben sich auf einmal
gegen das eigene Land drehen und das
muss Präsident Putin jetzt versuchen
sozusagen einzufangen er tut das in dem
er sagt da sind sozusagen einzelne die
aus
Karrieregründen aus ähm Egoismus die
diese Verbrechen begehen die sich über
das Land Stellen ich glaube nicht dass
er damit durchkommt und sozusagen den
Wechsel schafft von einer einem einem
Lob dieser Söldnertruppe
die einen hohen Blut soll in dem Krieg
bezahlt haben hin zu einem jetzt
sozusagen zur hassadoren zu Verrätern
die auf Moskau marschieren da ist eine
große Kluft die muss er erklären und er
kann sie nicht erklären danke Herr Jäger
für diese Einschätzung und ihre Analyse
danke für das Gespräch sehr gerne ich
danke Ihnen